in this video i'm going to show you
exactly what apps and programs i
personally use as a west australian
architect
on the brand new
m1 ultra mac studio number one is
magnets magnets should be a default
feature on apple systems but
unfortunately it is not it is basically
an app that is replicating what windows
has done for years all it does is
literally snap your programs and your
windows to one side or another where you
see fit for your workflow i really got
sick of moving all the screens and apps
around without being able to just snap
them to corners split the screens in
half like you can do on the ipad so i
downloaded this app it cost a little bit
of money but it was worth every cent now
i'm sure apple is definitely going to
come out with this feature someday soon
but for the time being this is an
exceptional app number two is notion if
you haven't used notion before you're
missing out notion is a phenomenal app
that basically allows you to curate your
life now i can't exactly show you what's
on my notion because it is all private
client information so i'm going to show
a blurred out version as much as i can
but basically it holds all of my project
notes it holds all of my projects and
whenever i need to refresh my memory on
a project this is exactly where i go now
if you stay tuned to the end of this
video i'm going to show you a full
breakdown of every app on the system the
third one on the list is very obvious
and everybody should have some shape or
form of this program
for me it's onedrive onedrive allows me
to connect all of my projects across all
of my devices so if you aren't on some
sort of cloud system what are you doing
number four is team gantt and teamgantt
is basically a gantt chart that allows
you to schedule and program your work
for me personally we have a very large
team it requires a lot of finesse to be
able to manipulate and manage all of
those projects at once so the team gantt
chart allows a visual representation of
who's doing what when they're doing what
and when clients can expect their work
so if somebody rings up and goes hey
david where's my project where's it at i
can quickly look on this team gantt
chart and go no worries mate it's
exactly due on this date last but not
least is number five and that is pro
workflow there are a number of these
apps out there but for me personally
this one was the winner for architecture
simply put pro workflow is a time
management system all we use it for is
documenting time sheets and managing our
projects from a financial point of view
so you can check every single project
how it's going if it's doing well if
it's profitable if it's not
and how long a staff member or anybody
has spent individually on that project
specifically on that task and what
they've done in that time frame so when
a client asks hey david what did you do
for a hundred hours on this project all
you do is print out a spreadsheet from
pro workflow go here you go this is
exactly who worked on it when they
worked on it how long they worked on it
and what they did it makes all of those
hard conversations significantly easier
now just because i'm a nice guy i'm
going to show you exactly what's on the
m1 ultra all i ask in return is you
smash the like button down below for the
youtube algorithm so here's a quick
breakdown of what's on my dock running
through them one by one we have finder
safari to-do list outlook notion teams
calendar notes archicad 25 obviously
twin motion teamgantt and pro workflow
up the top we have onedrive creative
cloud which i have photoshop lightroom
and premiere pro installed and also
magnets that's it for me my name is
david thomich i'll see you next time